só é e vai falar realmente um carinho
aqui do meu projeto e desta mudança toda
que eu tive é que dói mesmo as voltas a
vida não é das voltas às voltas e demora
para decidir
já não dava mais continuar as voltas no
mesmo sítio
eu criei este projeto o projeto live
mesh eu tenho um início quando era mais
pequenina quando era pequena minha avó
era muito católica e dizia que se eu
pintasse vai todos os dias à noite podia
usar e pedi três acho que o preto os
dias 13 e hoje membro do desejo que era
os recusarem as pobrezinhas todos querem
fugir à minha volta e um de cor rosa
graças a deus hoje em dia já não visto
na cor rosa como antigamente portanto já
fiz um ótimo grande mas tinha um grande
sonho que era as pessoas serem felizes à
minha volta então quando ele mais miúda
é eu criei cirurgiã plástica
isto porque é eu andava de transporte
públicos com os meus pais e ouvir as
pessoas com os cantinhos de advocacia
para baixo semanalmente como alguns de
vocês em gestão e eu devia crescer
cirurgiã plástica por pouco os cantinhos
da boca pra cima
era uma coisa que ninguém sabe
calorosamente
infelizmente não entrarem em piscinas
entre psicopedagogia criativa e
essenciais me sempre trabalhei na área é
que neste neste evento estava com uma
cara não querem vinha e muito formal
também estava a representar portugal é
no brasil é portanto a minha profissão e
psicopedagogia uma vez durante 70 ante
eu fui pro direito da seleção portuguesa
de física pedagogo e entretanto na
altura eu trabalhava estava efetiva
ganhava muito dinheiro e quando eu digo
muito dinheiro plano 1.228 30 anos era
chegar a 23 mil euros por mês e
trabalhava realmente muito e estava tudo
dinheiro é todas as semanas comprava
roupa maquiagem vistoria é assim muitas
vezes comia sempre fora de casa porque
não tinha tempo para cozinhar em casa
tem empregada doméstica eo advogado e as
voltas mas já agora vou usar o que o
termo do tempo né de vila real e da vale
as voltas e xavi que a vida é mesmo isso
quer ganhar dinheiro e gastar o dinheiro
e ganhar dinheiro e gastar o dinheiro
numa altura importante na minha vida e
por que eu criei quisessem os povos
vizinhos e todos fossem frisar a minha
volta eu inscrevi em várias instituições
quando nós temos um vazio por dentro das
empreitadas vários outros inscrever no
engenhão as feições prazos geralmente se
é esse o caminho que nós percorremos e
eu escrevi na terra dos sonhos e no
banco do tempo ea terra dos sonhos tem
um lema que disse é que eu posso
desenhar é capaz de fazer e os ensinava
e ser uma pessoa diferente um suco fosse
mais sustentável mais saudável mais
econômica mais ecológica ou seja uns são
mais simples porque realmente quanto
mais eu tinha coisas por si que essas
coisas não tinham o meu vazio que tinha
um trabalho que tem o marido com quem eu
tenho uma casa tinha viagens posta 0 mas
no fundo no fundo eu era feliz cook com
as coisas que eu tinha e iniciando ok
então nesta fase
como eu disse eu escrevi no banco do
tempo e eu estava super empolgada porque
o banco tempo e trocas de serviço estava
imensamente empolgada é com as trocas e
conhecer outras pessoas da minha zona
mas o banco do tempo fechou e na altura
eu sentir me um caso como este faixa
agora estava tão divertida porque fazia
aqui trocas minha mãe para casa e envia
o eletricista e eu posso fazer trocas a
do serviço e fechou porque as pessoas
têm figurado impedido então no banco do
tempo da minha zona show porque as
pessoas não podiam ser vistos só queriam
dar coisas não criam poder é realmente o
poder é o mais difícil parece que nós
nos sentimos numa posição em que estamos
necessitados e que estamos numa posição
inferior digamos assim então nem sempre
é o que diz é visto com muito bons olhos
mas na altura urbano que o tempo tenha
fechado e eu decidir
olha vou ter uma idéia eu vou fazer um
grupo trocas no facebook e foi assim que
a minha vida trocas começou então eu
decidi ir viver trocas de minimizar esse
grupo de trocas e o projeto inicial e
viver apenas durante um ano os dias 11
horas e um minuto com 1.111 euros
é eu queria sempre ter algum dinheiro é
o dinheiro para me pagar as despesas de
casa água luz gás essas coisas que
realmente não há trocas aí dependendo
fez trocas comigo ainda
é méxico é era era por cento 12 mil é
ser realmente mais ecológica é claro que
inicialmente os meus amigos acharam que
não havia necessidade que eu tinha uma
vida muito instável porque agora é viver
trocas que não era capaz como é que eu
ia deslocar é por exemplo eu vivo na
linha de sintra tem que deslocar um
comboio autocarro para lisboa como é que
eu ia fazer isso e na altura é o que
maior lata do mundo acredita neste mundo
cor-de-rosa digamos assim eu dizia claro
que tudo é possível afastar questões não
tem problema nenhum e na altura dizia as
coisas assim o corinthians é brincar mas
eu no fundo sabe que tudo é possível e
nós quando temos um sonho conseguimos ir
muito mais além
é este projecto deu tantas outras tantas
voltas que eu consegui mesmo esta troca
esta troca de toda a gente quer é
impossível o trabalho sp há mais de três
anos e faz trocas concepta pois é
portanto aquela menina é de deslocar da
linha de sintra para casa é para lisboa
ao eas de combóio concretizou se e foi
por causa do teto eu estava a dar uma
palestra no tempo cascais eo acp e da
patrocinadora e discursava trocas 511 no
fim não tem que me ligar sem citar
estamos então foi o mais importante não
sei quem são os posiciona 2008 ver que
uma vez que você fazer mais algumas
trocas vai esta troca realmente foi é
mais fantástica todas as trocas com os
supermercados trabalham durante dois
anos
é num supermercado onde colavam
autocolante trabalhar e treinar e
restaurantes dentistas em cannes tudo
que vocês possam imaginar por aqui pra
fazer as minhas necessidades na época
uma das minhas necessidades
mas esta é realmente uma troca especial
porque o porto dá sempre um serviço que
não havia quer ajudar os turistas é
mexer nestas máquinas que nem sempre são
muito fáceis de mexer e esse trabalho é
muito prazeroso porque eu conheço
pessoas tudo mundo
claro que não posso falar muito com elas
porque eu pareço trabalho um cãozinho é
quando é altura de praia ou vender
bilhetes em duas máquinas mas pronto não
interessa nada mas é muito engraçado o o
oge doado é as outras pessoas
estrangeiros e também as pessoas mais
idosas que têm dificuldade em em
proteína
em utilizá las por cento fosse uma troca
grandiosa
ainda hoje eu faço trocas com a cp e é
uma coisa que eu tenho muito orgulho e
divertimentos outras trocas que eu fiz
traz algo em alguns exemplos esta foi
uma troca de um pedaço de terreno eu
percebi também rapidamente que era muito
mais fácil ser sustentável se eu tivesse
um pedaço de terreno e se pudesse
cultivar a minha própria comida então eu
organizar uma feira de trocas numa
instituição perto da minha casa em troca
10 mudar sem mas é como vocês já devem
calcular é minha vida de trocas apesar
de não ter despedido eu estava
efetivamente prime só pra viver trocas
minha vida não foi uma desempregada
normal porque eu tinha trabalho tantas
trocas por fazer era trocas treinaria
dentista no nem sempre eu nunca parei de
trabalhar e nessa altura eu não
conseguia minimizar a horta sozinha
então mais do que troca seu decide
partilhar o treino com dois amigos - e é
e termos a nossa nossa horta para
podermos ter alguns consumos outra troca
que eu fiz o hóspede 50 foi quando eu
comecei este projeto foi aprender a
andar de bicicleta
ora aqui está a prova que nada é
impossível eu achava que era impossível
a premiada busca mas não é de valas
bicicleta em lisboa um é uma escola
mesmo que dá aulas bicicleta de um
refeitório a aprender a andar de
bicicleta e nunca caiu foi uma coisa boa
e este também fez acreditar que tudo
aquilo que eu sonhava poderia mesmo
acontecer e andar de bicicleta pra mim
era uma criança do que eu não iria
conseguir andar é claro como as aulas
com muita paciência das pessoas que
estavam à minha volta mas foi uma
experiência muito interessantes nessa
altura da minha vida que eu achava que
nunca mais e andar de bicicleta na via
enfim a parte mais interessante do
projeto além de várias trocas de
organizar de milhares pessoas que eu
conheci palestra de que o dae
comunicação social nunca mais acabava a
parte mais direta mesmo mesmo foi eu
visitar comunidades
eu queria visitar as comunidades todas
portuguesas algumas com muitos
estrangeiros a viver obviamente é para
aprender a ser mais sustentável mais
ecológica mais saudável então escolhi
comunidades mais diferentes possíveis
nível religioso
a nível político a nível das regras de
funcionamento
esta foi a primeira comunidade que eu
tive que a mera alguns já devem ter
ouvido falar
é uma comunidade em odemira é conhecida
pelos milagres portugal não porque faz o
grande senão nada disso porque é o luxo
tem uma uma forma da agricultura que é
prima cultura e fizeram escavações na
terra fizeram um grande buraco e com a
pressão da água de chuva fizeram lagos
então eles mudaram completamente a
paisagem é naquela zona do alentejo
ficou tudo divergentes conseguem
consumir essa água que captaram das
águas da chuva não tem problemas de água
nem para jogar na próxima vai nem para
usar na cozinha e por cento é um projeto
é uma comunidade ao é um carinho avançar
alegando assim nestes nestes tipos de
sistemas têm uma cozinha solar também e
pronto nesta comunidade aprende isso
tudo eu sigo a troca em regime do fim
trabalhava seis horas por dia em troca
de comida e dormida é nesta comunidade
aprende a fazer muita comida italiana e
muita comida com flores comestíveis foi
assim uma coisa que me deu muito prazer
que eu gostei muito e aprendi muito
muito mais coisas
esta comunidade assim muito rapidamente
foi a mais difícil de todas chamas ilha
para isso é uma unidade perto da serra
do mar vão é uma família ou mais é e
sobretudo as grandes diferenças é que
essas crianças não vão à escola não
tomou vacinas andam descalços porque
acho que uns sapatos de estragar os pés
o que não deixa de ser uma verdade é a
coisa mais estranha digamos assim é
dormir ao relento e só comer em cruz é é
a parte boa desta semana e max 3 quilos
em seis dias não é só com micros e muita
frutinha portanto foi muito bom
é essa comunidade fez abrir muito é a
minha cabeça fez 1 pensar se realmente a
cidade que nós vivemos e é aquela que é
mais assustada dentro dos nossos padrões
nós achamos que é o viavél ir à escola
dos ervais senado ou seja todos os dias
eu ficava com uma nova pergunta na minha
cabeça
esta foi a comida que eu acho que isso
aí eu só uso no fêmur em um grupo de
música seguem todos resolvia
do início ao fim do dia é muito
divertido e possui acima naturais que os
carros não for atuar pois é
percebi que uma lata de feijão frade é
super fácil de comprar mais uma lata de
pescar não é assim tão fácil de uma hora
e meia tempo é esta comunidade eu trago
aqui pra vocês conhecerem por premiê foi
a mais sustentável todas é eu tenho um
pedaço de terreno onde fazem a sua
própria comida fazem os filiados
propunha manhã pão correm o pão tem 20
em azeite ou seja as cultivam tudo são
fantásticos mesmo e ea comida sabe
realmente combina eu nunca comi comida
sertão é comida vai ligando você vai
mexer nessas outras coisas sobre uma
loja trocas em coimbra é um instrumento
está uma casa de trocas é correr em tons
vendas estamos a reabilitar uma casa com
18 as folhas toda com trocas com as
empresas é a volta de todos vendas
apoiar o movimento das talhas não nos
vídeos é tetra é mas o epicentro desta
casa que ela vai ter vários espaços
todos a troca
vocês podem ir lá podem ficar usados
podem ter eventos podem ir à loja porém
eu ter um espaço oficina tudo a troca e
conseguimos um grande feito foi a
empresa de transportes leva geralmente
as pessoas lisboa pretos vendas quebra e
caio também entrou conosco neste negócio
das trocas então nós vamos dar formação
aos motoristas relações interpessoais e
em troca os vamos dar x número de
bilhetes por mês para os visitantes a
nossa desta casa digamos assim poder em
lisboa e voltar por cento muito
realmente está instalado em frente está
mesmo azul
agora já não é cor-de-rosa última no
último projeto anda uma mais um ano
atrás
é pra não falar dela o tempo projeto era
outro projeto porque além do sim à crise
e cirurgiã plástica tenha um outro sonho
que era ser apresentadora de televisão
então como é que a parte de engenharia
capaz de fazer com visual ter vindo da
terra dos sonhos eu decidi ter um
programa provisão para levar é convidado
surdo projetos o que fosse e ecológicos
e sustentáveis porque os projetos nunca
vão atualizar mas que existem coisas que
eles têm mas a acontecer em portugal
então fiz um programa de televisão no
canal lisboa na tv ela inclui as
convidadas e foi uma experiência muito
divertida e foi um projeto muito
desafiador porque eu conseguir tudo de
forma gratuita
tanto o cenário como o calendário como
uma tesoura com as pessoas da produção
tudo por trocas ao povoado e visou por
partilhas foi assim 11 mais um sonho
este último projeto já que estamos aqui
com com com esta imagem é o meu livro
todos os dias no meu blog portanto todos
os dias do ano do projeto aliás do dia
do enem nos dias 11 a 13 minutos
eu escrevi no meu blog chama viva a
troca e as pessoas diziam que eu devia
lançar um livro e ottawa em lançar um
livro normal só que não queria um livro
qualquer eu queria um livro que fosse a
troca claro
ora eu não andava viver trocas e dizia
que as trocas eram possíveis e depois de
uma hora para outra eu ganhar uma data
dinheiro não era congruente então eu
seria lançar um livro totalmente a troca
é minha vitória que também é mobilizador
é como eu é fez trocas com a gráfica ou
seja fez um site e em troca a gráfica
imprimiu livro
agora entro com uma dívida a minha
vitória por tentar resgatar milhas para
uma casa de uma sessão que militar com a
prata
estas trocas de sempre andar às voltas e
este realmente foi foi toda a troca e
por isso não tem valor comercial e por
isso não há forma de comprar tudo o que
é um inconveniente para mim porque toda
a gente o que comprar e eu não posso
vender não nem sequer ter valor unitário
se vocês não quiserem adquirir outros 11
exemplo a instrução também paulo década
vila real
o livro está online toda a gente pode
ler na editora também destaques méxico
podem trocar comigo 11 exemplares com
objetos um abraço o texto é uma canção
olha nunca sabe
portanto use a imaginação e se quiserem
o livro podem fazer trocas químico é
entretanto acho que não não tem muito
mais a contar mas teria muito mais para
vos dizer para partilhar as outras foram
tantas tantas tantas os títulos que eu
conheci as pessoas que eu conhecia e
tantas voltas que se voltar a trabalhar
é este viver troca é muito interessante
e as trocas realmente são uma nova forma
nós podemos viver na cidade obviamente
não totalmente a troca porque aí essas
coisas nós precisamos para viver mexe
precisamos sempre de uma certa segurança
porque a cidade é feita com dinheiro
então eu decidi voltar a trabalhar ea
quarta do mês
mandei um email para os meus conhecidos
pra uma data de gente no dia que tinha
um irmão na caixa de cocaína na caixa de
mensagem ou imagem é então é um trabalho
anticíclico voltasse
tanto a vida dá muitas voltas que acho
que vou voltar ao meu trabalho não da
mesma forma que voltava a trabalhar há
15 anos por dia
com certeza só em part time e também com
trocas mas às vezes é preciso não
ajudarmos a volta a dar outra volta e
pensar nos onde realmente nós temos um
de pertencermos e o que queremos
realmente fazer para sermos felizes e
agora com certeza ser feliz é ser um
crime a troca não querem pôr dinheiro e
andar continuar as voltas para a versão
juízes cada vez mais